oh it's puns out guns out as we knock
out selections of what you should be
watching this week weighing in this week
along with the third Creed movie comes a
third season of the Mandalorian then we
have a rocking new series on Amazon
Prime video and a sequel series to a
certain classic Mel Brooks movie and
finally a special but absolutely not
surprising Awards pick that if you
haven't seen already hey what social
ousting like rotten tomatoes is here to
tell you this is the way on this week's
what to watch
[Music]
AKA theaters is Creed 3 the 9th
installment in the Rocky franchise and
the third in the spin-off Creed film
series and we are jumping out of our
seats to report it's having a strong
round one with the critics with a
certified fresh 91 make sure to check
back on the score throughout the week
but from our sea to we think the Creed
Trilogy will go the distance of 3-0 all
certified fresh and watch out for this
one-two punch Michael B Jordan not only
Stars once again but also makes his
directorial debut behind the camera for
this one that's right he directed it and
let's go for The Knockout here Jordan
has confirmed that this is the first
sports movie to be shot on IMAX cameras
immersing you into the fights on a level
no other sports movie has to date
landing on the world of Mandalore for
the first time is Disney Plus's third
season of the Mandalorian following two
very certified fresh Seasons already
floating out in the Galaxy now the big
Force pull for this season is Mando and
grogu will be visiting Mandalore the
Mandalorian Homeworld in order to see if
Mando may be forgiven for what he calls
his transgressions over the past two
seasons now call me a pessimist but if
you're calling your mistakes
transgressions you can bet it'll be more
than spank on the butt and with a sea of
friends and foes Mando has picked up
over the series like Bo Katan moff
Gideon and deep fake Luke Skywalker the
Allure of seeing these stories Collide
and Spark is what it's all about
speaking of check out this clip from
series Creator John Favreau hyping us up
on some of the advancements we can
expect to see from developing Jedi grogu
as we meet uh grogu this year he
definitely is not the same as he becomes
more acclimated and more comfortable in
the relationship with the Mandalorian
and as you receive training from the
greatest teacher around we're going to
see that he is evolving ladies
[Music]
and coming to Prime video is the
mini-series Daisy Jones and the six
which includes Reese Witherspoon among
its executive producers with stars Riley
Keough Camilla Marone and Sam Claflin
leading the way this limited episode
event will be presented in a documentary
style as it follows a rock band's rise
to Legendary status in the 1970s it's
based on the book of the same name by
Taylor Jenkins read which itself is
based on her experience growing up and
following the roller coaster career of
the one and only Fleetwood Mac and this
series may just prove why Thunder
doesn't only happen when it's raining
come on
arriving a whopping 42 years after the
fresh film history of the World Part 1
is the sequel series on Hulu history of
the World Part 2. with egot winner Mel
Brooks The Man Behind the classic movie
serving as executive producer this
series picks up where the predecessor
left off with comedy sketches parodying
civilization's most important moments
and figures well Shucks I can't wait to
see how they make fun of rotten tomatoes
in our episode we have one right the
show like the movie will be jam-packed
with big names including and this is
just a fraction Ike barenholt Seth Rogen
Danny DeVito taika ytt David Duchovny
Sarah Silverman not to mention the man
himself Mel Brooks lastly the series is
releasing across a special four night
event starting Monday they will be
dropping two new episodes daily until
Thursday
[Music]
and finally with Awards season in full
effect everything everywhere all at once
has been apps absolutely sweeping Awards
left and right this Indie darling is
dominating it on our Awards leaderboard
with over a hundred wins so far most
recently crushing it at both the
producers Guild and SAG Awards and with
the independent Spirit Awards this
weekend as well as the Oscars in only a
couple of weeks if you still haven't
seen the film one what is wrong with you
two now is the time to check this one
out and if you need the perfect place to
do this head over to voodoo's Awards
Spotlight page that has been beautifully
curated to give you ease of access not
to just this film but all the other
amazing Awards contenders as well there
you have it talk about a heavyweight
list that'll be the last one happy to
help you duck and weave your way through
what to watch this week I gotcha be sure
to let us know what you ended up
watching whether it was on this list or
not and be sure to check out
rottentomatoes.com for the latest
updates on scores and reviews for
everything mentioned here as well as the
movie and TV World At Large and until
next week fresh family stay fresh
foreign